serge dassault le fils de marcel élu pdg
de la société des avions marcel dassault
c'est un peu une surprise car on
s'attendait à ce que l'héritier de la
famille se retirent devant les
prétendants choisi en accord avec l'état
un rebondissement de toute dernière
minute qui a d'ailleurs conduit ses
représentants de l'état à s'abstenir
dans le vote
serge qui succède à marcel alors que
l'entreprise traverse quelques jolis
turbulences reportage laurent boussier
gilles berrut sans serge dassault
polytechnicien 61 ans père de quatre
enfants il a été ingénieur d'essais dans
les usines de son père avant de devenir
en 1967 président de l'électronique
serge dassault depuis cet après midi il
est aussi président des avions marcel
dassault
une élection difficile qui s'est fait
avec l'accord tacite du premier ministre
mais sans l'appui du ministère de la
défense
une élection sur son nom ne sera jamais
remplacé serge sera autre chose alors
c'est une nouvelle ère à nouveau patron
aura quel sera votre première décision
ma première décision sera de travailler
avec tout le monde je n'ai pas de
laisser repartir à prendre ce que je
ferai c'est de de m'attacher à avoir la
commande du rafale à l'issue tech nos
services à directional pour l'armement
et puis a travaillé que monsieur
delétoile pour avoir exportations plus
efficace plus importante d'une offre de
mill serge dassault va donc assurer une
succession difficile dans un moment
particulièrement délicat
les ventes d'avions civils restent
marginales quant aux avions militaires
un seul contrat à l'étranger étaient
signés cette année neuf mirage 2000 pour
l'un côté à venir le prototype rafale
est certes très performant mais il
semble un peu isolés en europe et on
attend toujours d'éventuels partenaires
pour sa fabrication
enfin le principal client de dassault
l'état ne semble pas pressé de passer
comment cette relative baisse d activité
vient d'entraîner une baisse des
effectifs pour la première fois dans
l'histoire de cette société
700 personnes partant à la retraite ou
en préretraite ne seront pas remplacés
zone de turbulence donc pour serge
dassault alors même que ses quatre
vice-présidents sont contestés par le
gouvernement